[Music]
on march 18th zack snyder's justice
league will finally arrive on hbo max in
all its four-hour glory
fans of the dc eu and snyder himself
have been campaigning for years to see
the director's curse of the 2017
film which was pretty much obliterated
by moviegoers and critics at the time
justice league currently holds a measly
40 rating on rotten tomatoes
which actually seems kinda high
considering the intense degree of
vitriol the movie has attracted
since its release regardless the version
of the film that joss whedon brought to
screen
seems destined to be reduced to a
footnote in the greater dc eu
with snyder's definitive curt poised to
replace it in the official canon
at least that's what the early critical
responses seem to suggest
now that critics have finally gotten
their hands on the snyder cut
they've taken to social media to give
their spoiler-free thoughts on the film
and if they're any indication then zack
snyder's justice league
shouldn't have a hard time surpassing
that 40 mark
but short the response to zack snyder's
justice league is glowing
critics overwhelmingly agree that the
film surpasses its predecessor in every
respect
suggesting that it really is the
satisfying well-rounded movie
that joss whedon just wasn't able to
produce sean o'connell of cinema blend
shared a lengthy response to the movie
on his twitter feed
one that claimed the snyder curt is the
best film in the dc eu thus far
he wrote this is the epic version of the
movie you thought you were getting in
2017
it's a fantastic continuation of the
story started in man of steel
but also a thorough extension of the
mythology of these beloved characters
o'connell also made sure to note that
the movie is not perfect however
citing too many of zack snyder's
trademark slow motion sequences
as one of the movie's particular flaws
meanwhile rotten tomatoes certified
critic
fico quangiano had nothing but positive
things to say about the film on twitter
he wrote zack snyder's justice league is
truly epic
superior to the 2017 version in every
way
amazing action and score every character
shines and story arcs follow through
from mos
and bvs can't believe this exists
incredibly satisfied and so
so worth the wait brandon davis of the
phase zero podcast tweeted
the movie is epic the characters just
matamore they have purpose and emotion
the villains are intimidating
cinematography is beautiful
it's exciting it's hard to believe
anyone thought this story should be
canned
critics scott menzel also promised fans
to richard character developments they
had hoped for
out of the snyder cuts for our runtime
tweeting
snyder's justice league is one of the
best superhero movies ever made
the longer weighted cut lives up to the
hype and feels unlike anything we've
seen in this universe before
each character is fully realized and
gets their moment to shine
some critics made a point of
highlighting the importance of the
movie's change in director
after all even in the light most
generous sweden he and snyder
undoubtedly have entirely different
approaches to making comic book movies
and nowhere is that clearer than with
zack snyder's justice league
as grace randolph tweeted the snyder
kurt is a master class and what a
difference a filmmaker makes
joss whedon did do a hack job on zack
snyder's vision and it is heartbreaking
and fascinating to see
the film is a true justice league story
and snyder's best film to date
beyond that it seems like critics can't
get enough of ray fisher's performance
as cyborg
fish's nion traumatic experience working
with weiner is now an infamous stain on
the original kurt's legacy
fortunately it seems that zack snyder's
justice league portrays the character as
he was truly intended to be portrayed
forbes scott mendelson tweeted two
reasons to watch
the action climax is much better and
cyborg gets to deserve spotlight
booyah still mendelson also lambasted
the movie for its long runtime
a very popular criticism among critics
against this cut of the movie
considering it seems to get so much else
right however it's unlikely the fans
will really care
either way they'll finally get their say
when the movie arrives on hbo max this
thursday
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you